let's go to hector he's live near far
hills in the 215
all bundled up good morning hector a lot
of snow behind you
i wish i was more bundled up bundle up
bundled up
good morning to you guys it's still
snowing out here and it's still pretty
cold
take a look at all the snow accumulating
here at this park we are at north tower
park where we've had a lot of snow
falling here overnight we have people
out
we actually saw some people out as early
as 4 30 in the morning
and a lot of people walking exercising
with their dogs that is nemo out there
in the distance
nemo uh let's see we can call nemo over
so this is actually nemo's second time
in the snow i'm told his first time was
when we had that snowstorm
in 2019 and look everyone's just having
fun out here
nemo sir nemo hey nemo
nemo right okay here come here so uh
it's been snowing almost nonstop
and you can just see how fun it is this
dog is having a lot of fun out here
um and yeah you know we saw snow falling
around midnight out here we've seen a
lot of families enjoying the snow
and for us it's not our first time here
i believe we have video from back in
2019
is that right we have video from 2019
when i did a snow angel here at this
park
i'm not sure if it's playing
all right so yeah we do have that video
of me doing the snow angel
and i guess why not i wonder
what's underneath oh this is snow
but you can see all of the leaves are
underneath the snow
demos just running around in circles
look at them look at them
hey nemo come here all right
nemo is so happy oh my goodness my back
is so cold
oh hector oh but
uh check out my hair look how awesome it
looks
um but yeah you know make sure you
bundle up
wear several layers i'm wearing a few
and that wasn't enough for me this
morning
anyway what do you guys think oh wait
hang on i think i lost my
we see you earpiece you know we know you
are too excited to do that
but that was a perfect snowy